[LW] It's May 1st, 2015.
This is Lynn Winterreise interviewing Patricia Flores. So
please, uh, tell me a little bit about yourself in your life before
your disability.
[PF] Born in ?Birdseye, California, um, to
lower-middle class parents and
very hardworking parents, very hardworking family
and um, uh, parents that
wanted me to do whatever it was happy.
So, you know they weren't the kind of parents that wanted me to
be either you know either, you know a lawyer, or a doctor or an MBA
they wanted to go out there and do, you know whatever it was that
So, um, when I was in high school I found
out what that was and that was art and art history so
Um, when I told them that they were like, "Oh, that's fine."
So, that's what I ended up doing. I ended up
going to community college first and then transferring to UC Santa Barbara
back in the early 90's, oh my God. I think I just dated myself
and got a double BA in Art History and Art Studio
and then eventually after about a three year
Gap, went on to what ended up being my first
?indistinct which brought me here to first time around. [interviewer] What year?
That was in 1998. Uh, no 1997, sorry.
yeah, '97 um and
Uh, I had gotten into the Bard Graduate Center for Studies in the Decorative
Arts Designer and Material Culture which is in the Upper West Side.
And at that time they were only owned one town-house. And, I think now they own like 3 or 4 on that block
[laughter] [cross-talk] so
we moved, my husband and I at the time, moved out here
here.
We were very excited because he was an artist so
you know he was very excited about. Coming out here as well
Um, and actually when we were out here we were
out here for about 7 years so, um
during this time we were out here, he ended up going to Colombia to get his MFA.
which he never planned on doing
but, figured while he was here, he might as well do it
.
So, I was going to school and after my first
semester a job opportunity came up at the Metropolitan Museum of Art
which I
Which I got. Which is in the department European Sculpture and Decorative
Arts. As their collections management
assistant at the time and then later on I became one of their coordinators
was to begin digitizing all of their
object records collection, er catalog.
Basically begin putting all that information onto
the web for the first time
for them they were basically one of the last of the big museums in the country to do it
it at that time so it was a pretty big undertaking.
Was only supposed to be a 2 year project and I ended up
on that project for six years. And it was still going on when I left, so.
.
It was a pretty amazing opportunity to be there for 6 years and
be able to work with the curators and to be able to work with the objects.
Yeah. It was really great. And I ended up
working with one of the curators in the department on my thesis
at the time as well. I was working on these other ?tapestries
. That were. England's.
Tongue people. Who's not a director. Yeah yeah so
that was pretty special. Actually. Well
. OK thing is just fine. So
and so similar. To those on one
. Hand I was actually at work. That
morning. And I get a phone call. From. My husband
. And his office is only a few blocks away. From.
The World Trade Center. So he called me you know he was one
of the chief of the. Museum
. Right around the.
Clock. Said it was him online
. Getting a call from a carrier for Germany
.
They're saying. Who is watching it
and so that was our first indication that something was terribly wrong
. Today.
You know that there are two people called the same thing.
But you know people are starting to get worried because of the fact that they knew that
someone. In the department. Had someone
.
Down. There and write ups in time
as well. The chairperson. Of art
. Department director who had just gotten.
There. Just got back.
From going.
From. There basically saying get out
. Yeah basically said you know. So it's like
. Terrorism. They called. The target.
That. Building. And so they were working
. Theory. All the. Guests first
. And you know they object
. Yes. You know. It's. Just.
Metairie. And. Then they just sort. Of
insecurity. You. Go. To start. Out. Without.
Thinking.
And we were. In them
.
And. Because we had to go through a number. And
start a sighting. OK do.
You
.
Know Why I mean in case of somebody coming in
case anything were to happen to the vein.
Everything. Extreme violence here in town.
God.
You know done stories. Safer right
. So
. You know I couldn't think straight
. OK thank. You. You.
See. He had told me that he had watched
the stock. Market. And he
was sitting there watching people. And.
That. Was the last thing. You know I was
that end of the study here for the day
. Because another round. And
. Great. Sorrow
. You know. I'm making the
decision. After.
That and after they had to say to him that I would actually
. Can.
Tell my plus
you know foreigners and historically and and they get stuck on the trains
in my car.
So. So basically. You. Know
.
When. You get
. There. Trying to. Dismantle.
It. And of course once you hit fourteen that's been hit
. Very. High scrutiny
. Of the times. Now
.
What. They.
Tell me. Like it seems people can and.
Testament. To. You
. And. You know
. Finally I. Start walking. Toward. The
Hudson. And by.
The way. And
Sterling.
You know of course you got the worse it was
. But that's also you know his. Officers
. More toward. The river as well so
I was just like.
On. So just. Walking
. Around. Walking running walking and walking around
and you know the clergy.
You know they were suddenly like. To us.
And. Everything's heard and because by then by now they
had already gone. And. I
didn't. Understand that. I didn't know. At all.
If. You didn't register You were people walking out
. You know covered.
Just
.
Say they were fire.
Back. But all of this is weird. It just doesn't make any
sense. And. I
finally made it to his building his office building
. And by then there was nobody there. Dylan is
closed today.
And I'm. OK she is.
And. By then I was so completely disoriented
. Because everything was just covered in signficance evening
. And so when you're walking
in. Or. Broadway
. Teams only really.
Forty six was. Really close
. And. I could not
understand it although until I got. Close
and then I. Thought. I finally looked at
. Captain India. And we're
all down on the ground. Doesn't
caper. Is so completely
in shock I couldn't understand that. All I know
is that I haven't been here.
And. I looked up. And
. Went in the world
. You know and I finally stopped it was like what what
happened. They're gone. They fell down
. Yeah. No.
Way. And I
did not know. Where. He could be.
So I just kept walking. Going.
On
.
And then I remember. That. Hour.
Later
.
And you know seeing wasn't on
The ground. Now. Who knows I mean where are you
now
.
And. We. Don't
Think literally pastor. With. That
. Same. Or.
Christian Identity. For him to do
is. Talk of it too. It's like.
It was. A really well conduit
if well pasturing in which is actually
where they crossed.
It's turned into like a
.
Little. One
. I'm just so you know
decided OK you know maybe they're related. I mean this Congress
. So. I decided. To
.
Turn. In that direction. I was
hurt. By this because it was just an ear
. And I mean so it's taking everything
. From. The time I got home that night
I say. Because that is it
. Was it was just a minor. Problem
.
And. I wasn't that far
away from it.
So I. Don't understand how I know
. How much.
Wiser this time have elapsed during the day. All I
know is that it
.
By the time it was close to him
it was. For. You
. And
not in any sense of timing.
At all. Again the
building two already broke down.
And worked with volatile or. Yes. Or
. No it
. Was Actually I
think most of these cameras caught it.
On. Day.
One. But I was actually quite close to
the. Notice was enormous
.
And. It's like I started
hearing him I hear it
.
But I didn't really think about Michael.
And. So
I. Was correct. In that
life. He was frantic. Yeah. Yeah. I was that.
You know. I.
Mean he's he's pretty easy to
.
Figure out. Because. He's he's pretty
predictable. And. You know I.
Mean. It was funny because. Well it's funny
how the plan. You know.
When I saw two sentences.
Leave. Him. You know because it was innocent civilians like the trio
right
. Right spot and I was trying to get through there.
To get across the street. And I was but and I say
. The State. Department. And
the red. Cross.
You were only sixteen when you began
just cussing at them and.
Finally left one of the. One of the main street
. In this great building. And. You
. Ran up the stairs and. Only.
One. Thing
. From. Them like. Trash cans
is art and there. Is like
. A relief in a group of. Well
.
You know what when I actually walked in and saw him sitting. Back
. Down.
So. You know. Me and I knew they had seen. Quite a
bit. Ago.
And I get you know when he saw. Me. I'm going to
. Miss this place. So
. This match is like
.
You know I didn't know how he was doing you physically.
Injured. And he was
with a talking. Something
and I wasn't there and I didn't.
Know. So
.
Yeah. And Burton being.
There in the muck for so long.
Which is what they've been talking about for the last thirty or forty
. Years.
So when when did you start to realize it's
.
Probably four months later. Really. Yeah. You know I mean I still
have that ring in here every day.
Yeah. But then. I have been
. Working on and trying to get. My. Thesis
. Of. Him. And. You know.
Actually. Partnering. With my.
With my visor one day and I'm seeing him and I
have been kind of dizzy. And. It was really
exciting never felt anything like that before. And by the
time I have made it to his office I was actually running in the
stuff. That's been locked in a straight line
. And he's like Are you OK. Because
I ran into the doorway and then I ran to his parents because
.
He's like.
You know you might you know not really
just for the past two days.
And I haven't see. My doctor tomorrow
.
Right. So so I went to the doctor
. With donors with
possibly an inner ear infection. And was
Dana's Berga. Which I. Never. Had before. I
. Had never experienced. Before.
And. You know it's like well you just keep an eye on it and it gets worse
. You know.
Really. Man I was
.
Back in his office two days later. It's worth
to the point where you can
. And.
Say. OK We're going to probably hear ya
.
You know and of course let me remind you of my here too
And so. You know he
started a string of referrals to.
Specialists. Which went on for a.
Year. He did you precisely make that connection to
be down there with the with the big noise right
away.
Right where.
I can make and I didn't make a connection with them in ways I mean more of a connection with. Dust
. Time. You know. Down there. Was
. A.
Long one you know. We really don't know.
I'm just surprised you know.
You are. You know I'm here and it. Was
missing a lot of work.
And. That wasn't going very well. You know
I can't. Turn. It. Over.
Winter. And.
You. Know. It. Isn't willing. Or. Able.
And. You're hearing the breaking point you
.
Know this was OK. Right. Away. At that
. Least as far as I knew
. At the time. It. Wasn't
. Just. Later. OK
. So so here
I am me stumble upon. My. Poor
. Back. And say. OK.
I know what you're dealing with a person reading my. Own.
And to rest
.
For a circular. Build So basically he was telling me
. Something that there was like an engine to my system
. So they sent me to the
three little canals that are here. That
maintain your bounce. On. And
. That really all it has done is. Physical
. Like.
Really. So yeah
.
So I ended up there for two years
Back and forth and patience.
Yeah. Go into rehab and psychological.
And the physical rehab. No it's actually really
interesting stuff. They basically work with your balance your
coronation.
Here had a. Great mission
. And basically have to do a lot of like
walking exercising that is currently doing
. Their own things like walking
and walking up and down stairs. On the. Treadmill
which to this day I still cannot do.
I do learn to. Get on
the. Exercise bike. Without getting sick.
For. A few years ago. But I haven't actually been on. A.
Bike. For many years. And
. I'm.
Here. And still. You know. Two
cars in the backseat. Fancy
. Pants and. Busses are still
really are busy. Planes are really aren't the same
. An amenity the only thing I can do is trains.
Which is strange. But they said no. It's not strange
. You know. Quite a few people do
. Treat me
. Well
.
Anche really the best way to deal with Vertigo is. Walking
. Walking is your natural calibrator just
. Walking you do. More.
Once controlled. So I did and so on just to
keep it will be critiqued Philip to all these years.
So. Yeah. It's always going to be there. And the
tonight is to night is still there. So you know I'm going to have. You
know. I still hear rain. So are you going to can
both eras. Yeah yeah so so
basically here I started noticing the here and going in two
thousand and eight.
So it took me seven years but.
Most of the archaeologists that I've seen told me
that it was probably starting to go from day one. That just a very
slow rate. And then over the years it
. And it had started
going just and right here that's where most of the
really big screen. And so what I was
hearing. At the end of. It
. And. I
noticed it. When. I started. When. I was. Down
here. I was working at the time for an
article. Their. Own. Band
. Program. Manager. And. Was teaching.
At night. And.
I've noticed. That being at a big lecture all I can. Hear
. My students. And so. I. Decided to go get it checked out
. The. Past
. Year or. So and. So I was like
.
Oh. You didn't get it right away. Yes. I know it is OK
to
. Do this
so you were able to really. Big knowledge what was happening and not
going to go away.
Yeah I think it was just because I let it right there with Ergo I was like OK this
. Is normal. This is coming towards me
so. I was really scared
. But at the same time I was like yeah. You know I mean.
I. Can't teach if I can hear. You need to figure out what's going
on. So. I just. Go.
We don't know we don't know what's going on. But. We're talking about a loss
to. Figure out what's.
Going on the kind of three Richard has been very supportive family in general you can
see my family where.
They don't understand what's going on I'm scared. And rightly
so. My
. Current theory that. Time.
Is. Going. To. Claim. It is in
use. And I wasn't there
.
As a whole. Which is wrong. So
. Yes.
Literally. With Tommy I don't know.
They're. Actually trying
to come to my They're my parents. And you
sit there and tell my therapist and Myspace I don't believe in there and
you just sit there and. You know.
And. And.
It was hilarious.
That's. Your kind of. Knew. It was going to be over
.
And you're also dealing with this here in the US well
On. This
. C two
thousand and twelve. Their
boss. Bent. Oh
. Yeah two thousand and twelve
. So
. And that it was going. Quickly
. At that time. Three My
doctors at once. Because.
You know. They didn't like what they saw. Right
so they. Can. Sense
.
When you're listening to yours. And what you mean when you state
For both ears. And it's going fast
. Yeah this might have
been. A network
. Talk to keep work
. And
. You know it's tough enough when you
. Are not getting full support. Around. Here. It's been
. Tougher line. OK for support from
. Letters. So.
I had lost my job looking article. On
. The big house at my house. Marks
. That I. Bought for me. In the H.R.
office and front page or picture. As the architecture
of.
The City. Now what are you kidding me. Places illegal
. Really. Yeah.
And then as I left home and got an attorney. And
yeah. I am but I couldn't keep it going. Business
and Planetary Sciences go go for five hundred dollars an hour
.
I just lost my job.
Where I learnt all the cases though
. I do. Not like the
rule irony. Of it all. It's like you know most. Of
the. Time. You know attorneys will continue until Jesus
I'll. Get them. Back. You know it isn't the other way around
or to paint on.
They actually win the case
.
Yeah so that particular. Case
. I mean. Because.
So. I hear.
All of them. So you were working
.
I was unemployed for a little. While
able to get more teaching so I was teaching or full time for about a
year.
And then. I was getting really
stressed out. From both of teaching and just
. You know stress or
. You know losing a job
not having health insurance.
And you know the whole the whole thing I mean to have to cover yourself. For
health insurance in California and fire thousand dollars
a month. Well
. Yeah. And I was just an adjunct
. Professor.
You know making. For over two
.
Years. So
. You know.
When it's a slave. And you had to move back to
California in which year two thousand and four
.
I was laid off. From the article. And.
Didn't.
Mean. It doesn't mean the crisis
. Right now and you know
.
This is right at the time that I started losing. So you know I was going
through. You know those various images of
. Disabled people go OK.
Because. Without. Them. Knowing
. You know when you get to a certain point
where. I just can't anymore. I got a
point where I couldn't because like you know. One thing
. I ended up losing. Our
because I can no longer.
Even with a hearing aid.
Yeah I hear you need a really terrible when it comes to. Guns
. And especially if they don't have the right equipment
. We have a telephone. Line. But
. You know what they.
Call digital tolling systems
. Or. Didn't. Do. Anything
. It didn't matter at all. So
.
Any improvement in our past so
that septic own us. Space discoveries are
just completely. Wrong
.
And it was worthless. It's not here
. And it just straight out tell
. Me What we need and I thought
. It was scary. Town finds that
. Later. They lay
off a bunch of people. One.
Again if the same. Question
. What do you do
on the last job I lost. Because I was
like right after. I was going to. Sell
.
You a note and I decided to go back to school
. Because you know I
have lasts five years has
. Been. Employed for.
Quite
.
A while. When
. We. Bring.
It back to. You know.
Yes QUESTION How it stresses making crazy
so I can't. Do this anymore. And
. Here. Is basically running away.
I had just gone through a fire study a Stanford
University. System they were doing
. A year. Hospital
. Where I was very
lucky to get.
Prolonged. Exposure
therapy is you have to
go in and continuously tell the story
. Over. And. Over. And over.
There are. Attempts to do is move those
memories from one part of your brain to the other. So that you no longer have
. The flashbacks panic attacks. And
. Mirrors. It basically removes it from the
part of the brain that looks at it as a
. As a
structure. Or as a you know. Form. Of.
Fish or. You know pain
. And instead
you.
Know and you know it isn't received at
. Rome. With those memories and
. So. On. It's actually pretty
.
Old. It's a pretty old modality
. But that. They were
.
Looking. Pretty extensively. Again.
It's. A mentality. For. Returning soldiers
. I. Guess. But they also wanted to
bring in. Another. Another. State where
you know. There were other cases
. That. It.
Took. And that was helpful for you.
Extremely. Extremely angry. It took away the bus that
took away the panic attacks mostly. It didn't take away the
nightmares. I still have nightmares. But to this
day to this day I suddenly thought. You know it's not
. Universal. But it.
I mean I can live with my. Sons I don't have the flashbacks anymore.
That's why I lost.
Because in the classroom. Well I was
in. A. Part. Around
. Wasn't you.
Know. Going from one community college to another
.
Private. School in Cisco and
We were stopped in Oakland. Pretty big
transfer. Stuff. In conversation
. We were stopped at quite a
while so I called them to let them know they. Are public.
Or.
In my ear or minutes late. You know the director's like a problem.
I'm. Literally like your children
. Are. Trying to. Play with.
Please. Break their
. Machine and dogs
and you know they were trying to. Clean up
. From Dr Gray.
Really close and they want to make sure that they're
well they get on the train
all the trains that were in the changing world started it all worth it
and you know because of all those years after nine eleven and
. All. The. Cars and all. The
. National Guard. Are all. Over. In
the.
American subways and streets live in. Tokyo.
Right so when they're. Down. Which is
pretty normal. For me. I mean if something. Happened I was. Not
.
Always say.
A military base but. Someone. Else
. Can be. And. Why
. Every
.
Time. One of them are coming to town. Every
October. And. Saying. I can't do you know
.
So. By the time I go
. To school. I
mean. You know I haven't quite. Gone down yet. Walked into
the classroom and she looked at me and she's like. You
. Like. It will be
.
And you. Know I. Mean
. I. Called Senator. Golden.
Yes. With no explanation. Oh yeah. Student
your health at. All. And
told me years ago. Suck it up
. Yes. And I was in the presence of the
staff psychologist. And. We're all
. Kitty and just sitting there she's like
. Oh my God I. Just said that
look you know I. Couldn't take the
cake. They are.
There. And any of the fun.
Then when true victims of nine eleven think that any of those one
thousand you never because I could never prove that I was younger
.
I didn't work. Through. That. I have
and. I try to show them
his business card which showed it to us. Because I
couldn't stand that. Day. I hate it
. And because it was so many years later. When
Einstein. Popped up. I was. A
. Direct. Correlation
. So. Yeah
. Thank
God for. So to this day. So
. I've had to stop. Talking
or virgins. Contributor insurance because I
just said.
Intuitive thing. When did this begin you mean. Because to
create existing It wouldn't be covered.
I could have a look at it proper existing
but if I try to. Connect it anyway and
. So
. On. Then
. That's been hard. Because they
are all you know more. Than
.
One.
Cell.
Until then you know what made you decide to be so you were being
treated in San Francisco for everything and that's where they discovered
I was being.
Treated there eight years. Or.
So and then what made you decide to come back east. Yes
yes. You. Know I. Couldn't. Sleep.
Yeah it. Was my husband.
And I have a very lucrative. Career position. And
.
I. Have been trying to decide. If. I was.
Especially after. Sounds
. Hears. Her. And
. You know I have been
thinking.
About going into disability
. Because I've gotten
very interested. In the air
.
Traffic. Yeah just based on my own experience and you particularly with the you know
employment discrimination that was the
first.
Notch I think for me because I was just such a huge presence in my life
.
And so I actually did think
. It
was.
It was actually in college. And
. There was actually a
couple weeks before the end of it. Yeah. Yeah. I
actually. Ended up being. Of
the really. Big. Words. OK
. And then when I got back to Oklahoma.
On Oh I should have loved. Back here helping all my
friends
. It was kind of one of those situations
.
Because I still have a lot of friends here. And we. Live
. Downtown. Manhattan
. And actually one of the women I stayed with us too it's a
good.
Thing. She would be just a little village.
For. Me. Yeah that
Berkman for her but it still
. Didn't make it easier for so. Long
. You. Really Want. To be here. To help
. But
. Going back to
. The unification state then you're
. Like OK this is a sign
. Telling me to. Make a change
. That's. All.
It's an issue and never ask them for money. And they just
happened. A little.
Bit. And they and they weren't.
Always part of.
It. But it was decided to because I think that here
.
You go if you're a talk. By. The woman whose
. Thesis advisor. And he was marvellous. She's
an assistant professor.
Teaching disability studies are
. Funded
.
The project right now I'm talking books. So might looking around at all
equipment and all of us. Fell
.
On. Her when her research assistants for that. Project are now
. On. The
. Issues of the. Paper. And
. I call them
. An ass to. The public.
And. You know they ask you to look at something
. And so.
And. So forth.
So I. Met. Her. In. That department while
it was here. And.
I. Decided why it was actually going to only
apply to this day. When I. Got. There I could only go on
knowing that I didn't want to go
.
So. I applied to this. One
program. You're constantly gauging. You
.
And in the meantime have any plans to do about me and living
with my cousin and his wife. So while
I was waiting to hear about them anyway. If I had of the apartment.
And. You know just about ready to leave. And
. Then I got the email.
Resolutions. And that was like two days before I left. And received a
scholarship I got some funny. Yes.
And I continue to get funny.
Here and you know that's actually a master's program.
When you get into the country.
So you can
see. You know the whole time I've been here I
mean it's just been very weird I mean to me. That I
made the right. I mean
everybody here has been extremely supportive. You know
I recently had to. Make that really hard decision
to put up. My graduation for another term. Which was
. That was a hard. Decision. But I also
had to think about my own. House. And I hope this
. Question. Hasn't been. Since. OK
. So. You know I've had a couple of
big scares Well I've been here. Really
. Well I mean here. Was
their. Hand.
I have it return. Really
stubborn diversion business here which is basically
forced me into this project
. But this doesn't mean
. You know it's
basically since
. You
. Know. And so
you know you have. To. Just let it
go. At least that
used to really be fixed. Yeah. You know
now to. The point where. I. Can't. I can't fight you
. I have to just let you go
. And.
Just you know plain brown. And then I can continue
working.
Any tree leading to what she saw. Oh yes what happened
to us both.
I saw his body parts on the ground. Near
.
As I
. Can
. Never. Really. Get.
Those. Yeah
I said thinking sounds yet. To turn on
.
You know. As I can see a
therapist pleasantly.
Didn't. Seem to be.
And so you have hearing aids nearly as you know have hearing aids
.
I am you know categorized a profoundly hard hearing
. Which doesn't mean you're totally totally
tough but pretty close to
take these out. I can't hear much.
When I have. A man I. Hear. OK
It means I haven't started losing clarity yet
but the last time I have it here and asked their
.
Allergists to notice they're starting to lose that.
The first time. The clarity of the sound clarity it sounds particularly clarity of
words. And that's not a good sign
. Actually section without sign. Because the work they are doing
that you lose a lot of activity here and are
. Yet. And the more you want to start you know.
OK Do you want. To. Have a good
I have thought about it and. There is
one real risk. And one of the things that
popped up. When he did. Writes the CAT scans a few years
ago it was. My carotid. Artery
. Runs too close to my inner ear.
You know it's one of those logical
.
Things. That you know you would never see.
Which are. Wrong. And. You know
unfortunately you know to. Start cutting things they'll start
shoving wiring in there.
So close to your car. It isn't it that's
all.
So you might have to prepare myself for.
This. You know I've already started on his language.
Happy. I. Think I'm. Trying to keep up with
causes which is here.
And he is. Very ill.
And this really wonderful little place
. Yeah it's like this.
On it's like this little converted studio apartment it is so
wonderful and they have it you look at such an offer to like these pieces
. And. You know they hold. Classes.
You know it's like it's quiet in there. You can have three fastest growing and there
.
You know you.
Know. Oh are you talking
. And the guy that
wanted to. Be
. A. Place. Where
. You know I haven't. Been able
to keep up with my classes this last Are they enough me to Texan
. I'm actually able. To make great to
have that kind of support. Yes yes. You know we really care about.
History. And. Culture
.
No I. Mean it's. It's. Really. I mean. I have
a tutor you know and I had started
. Their. Sister
. Her her sister
Puerto. Actually teaches at a.
School.
Now it's Kentucky
. And
. She says she saw and heard it
.
It's such a beautiful language today and. That's
why. I do.
You know attempted You know because I have to learn German French because of her
history. But you know I never easy
. But something which I find very easy to pick out just
because it's such a bore. All right
. I'm very visual. Artist Chris
. So that. Makes. It.
Easy to pick up which is good because I struggle with the other two
.
German in the different branches of it. Yeah
. You know when I was brands like you know. It was the most
horrible American trying to. Speak French.
So now they've got to say I mean what they're doing for you know it's all
that they can do all they can do.
You know that I will most likely to.
Go. And you go on a regular basis for check
ups
. You know at this point I go in when I change
. So we're all kind of at that point now.
Where you know I'm not expecting. That's not going to get back to
. You know my artist knows that you know
. That means. OK
. So why don't you
. Give. Us. The.
Results. And is there a rhythm that I mean is it
if you don't want to do it for a while
.
Literally every. Fourth.
Back. For a. Little while. So it so
. That's good news is. It's very
. Tense
. Good question. And
Sin ain't broke don't fix it
. Exactly exactly.
She told me it might hurt for a while and then it. Might start. Sat
. And talked. Fine. You know. That happens.
But because I bombed out so I asked. You know. It's
.
Not surprising
. What do
you mean when you see and get to the bottom of the Arctic ground.
Right now and I said at the very bottom. So when you
actually look at my over right now. Rather. Than one
. There isn't. One of.
Them. And then
that would mean it would. Get finished. And
that would preclude any here in the region
. Most likely.
So. How are you feeling about that.
I'm not going to. Get
. Her
.
Away.
Really then. Trying to be comfortable
. With what is
. A lot
of the work. I've done. A.
Lot. I mean there's so
much there's so much more than just. Physical
. Yes So much of this is mental.
As well. I think a lot of the work for
. Me. Of this. And also
just getting on my own. And caring way. So I
.
Should.
Say it was becoming a very. Helpful
. Relationship. I mean you know I
thought. He was a really wonderful
twenty or. Twenty two. Year
. Seventeen years married. Years. Ago
.
Sometimes those things come to
. Twenty years is
longer than many marriages
.
Don't.
Like experiences. It's something you learn. Yeah I
mean you're doing damage Mark. Is. This a.
Talent.
It's like. I was in the statistic just like.
Thousands of others. Still
. Remain.
All. Knowing. That. I've been able. To. Turn things around
. And. Acknowledge
. My. Life. And
. Want to
. Do something that. Makes them. Better
. And that educates.
Lies. And he just you know
all the discrimination. I. Went through. All those years
.
Hoping. To do. I don't want anybody
else. Going.
It's not necessary my life is very old very
successful. You know the. Past that
I am
.
Was it. Thought very highly of me and told
Her. That she looked at me again and
. Be interested
in. The age of eighteen. And
. I say as much as
the static I wanted to stay because I love my
job.
Then. She didn't see any significant
not. Really.
But it is. Uncomfortable difficult
.
And you know she.
Makes an example for me every day. So
you will. Get out there. That you. Think you know
because I'm the same person. Rather than the table or
. On. Just one
. They're. Pretty surprising that people would have that reaction to
slug people.
I. Mean same charter school. But no you were not
there. But no I don't have to suck
it up. Because I happen to be.
So anything else you want to say that you haven't seen
.
Today.
You know I. Wasn't just
. Talking about this it was also. A.
Couple in the anthropology department there were also.
Disability specialists in Iraq
. Everyone. In this
area. And. I. Think.
They and they're both parents are. Disabled children. So I
think it is. Daughter was. In
. Here. One day. So I'll. Sit
here as well. To. Talk about my story
.
But. I want to be on the other side hearing it it's a big honor
you know so that. You know what they say that you know
. Life gives you lemons you make lemonade to see you
take this you know really. Very difficult experience
and and get on top of other difficult experiences at the same time and be
able to say I want to create the most value not just for
yourself but for other people. Yeah. So it's seen
as. You. Know.
People
.
Want it you know that makes you very unusual that one could just
start to feel, it's me, I'm
just, woe is me. But to have a heart that
really cares about others is a great thing. [whispers] Thanks
Thank you. So much.